so
uh so 2002 2004 you're spending all this
time with
uh de palma are you driving him around
is he the one that you're driving around
yes i want how it worked is his son who
tried to commit suicide
at the prison this because he too was
arrested in the scores case
okay and also the one down in atlanta
georgia
i think it was called solid gold some
big strip club down there where all the
celebrity stars and uh and athletes
would go
he got arrested with greg there was
rumors that craig was cooperating
and greg arranged it that he would meet
with his son craig and pretty much
challenged him and said
you're a disgrace not only to the family
name you're a disgrace to kozanostra
so what happened was they found him in
his
um cell hung so greg de palma when he
came out of prison
he requested a one of those uh
released compassionate release and craig
the palmer was released
and put in a nursing home in westchester
now the irony of that is craig obama
went to all these nursing homes and
found
one and he specifically told the uh
the director of the nursing home that
there was not going to be any mob
stuff and the reason why everybody knew
greg de palma was a gangster
because of his was just the premier
theater days
so what happens within a week we had all
our meetings
at the nursing home all the wise guys
would come in there
and my heart ached when you see the
family members
looking at their elderly uh family
members
and surrounded by all these gangsters
who are either taking action
or or paying tribute payment to the mob
so greg de palma wound up running his
old operation he was
what i thought a good father or was he a
good
gangster because he was loving his son
and taking care of him but you know
it was a little weird because it was
also kind of selfish on greg because it
was known out there
that greg's son cooperated and that was
a reflection on him
so but of course greg the palmer's story
was not that he was cooperating
but instead it was the marshals who
killed him
i mean as outrage as that was that's
what he uh
he was putting out there in order to
cover himself in
in the gambino crime family was he was
he a
like a real real mafioso where his
loyalty was to la cosa nostra over
family where
he followed the code to the t was he
known as somebody like that
greg de palma was brilliant in this
regard
yes he had a big mouth but again like i
said earlier
that was great for the fbi he loved to
talk we love to listen
but the interesting thing about greg and
he told me this in confidence
when you make money in the mob you have
to kick
up you kick up to your soldier if you're
reporting to a soldier
you kick up to your skipper and then the
skipper kicks up to the administration
okay what greg de palma told me is he
gave more
than the normal amount because he always
felt that the more you give will keep
him in social graces
with the administration in case he
screwed up and greg the palmer
was known for that so he did play the
cozy nostra rules where he gave
money to his bosses in excess just in
case he messed up
they were going to leave him alone out
of it or maybe just you know
let him walk interesting so he had the
wisdom there to know that
uh let me make sure the people above me
are happy so one they're not paranoid
and two
i keep getting the favors and the
benefit uh was he a decent earner
himself or was he more of a
enforcer no he was a very good earner he
had a lot of construction companies up
in westchester
that were on record with him he had
control of a lot of union
uh greg the palmer was uh like i said he
was a celebrity and it was kind of weird
too patrick because when we would go out
to dinner
and we would go to these fancy
restaurants in westchester
honest people you could tell they were
successful businessman older
would come to our table just to shake
hands with greg the palmer
and reminisce about the great times that
they had at worcester
premier theater and greg de palma would
take their calling card their business
card
and you could see him looking at that
and saying how do i get in this guy's
pocket
how do i what can i get out of this guy
in the future
by the end of the day sometimes he have
20 uh business cards
and he was always thinking he was a true
closer nostra of
always thinking of where to make money
how to rob money in every regard
is is that is that his dna or is that
the dna the
co co la cosa nostra where they're
always looking at how can i get more
money of this guy in front of me
yes absolutely that is the dna with that
it's all about making money
you know and it's kind of funny when
when you hear them and
you see them constantly it's always
looking for
angles it's always looking of how did i
get over on this how do
i put the and the way they work is quite
genius is they put you on record
they think that you or your business
establishment
is going to be benefit from it and that
no one will mess with it
well along with that comes you got to
pay
and along with that comes that now you
own a restaurant okay so where are you
getting your produce
where you getting your wines where you
getting your linen who's doing your
garbage
they got the guys so they'll put these
people in place
and every place that they put in people
they put in
of course they're kicking back to the
mob so it's just
the way they work it's a constant money
making organization
of every way that they can because
that's what it's all about with them
it's all about the greed and that's all
i think i was
able to get into them because of the
greed
is you wave a little money you make
yourself to be the goose that laid the
golden egg
and there you go you have it now
question for you about that when you're
talking about you know hey
you give me some money i'm going to
protect you the mob of the 80s is very
different than a mob of the 2000 because
piston came and cleaned house himself
from 76 to 81. i believe he was there
for like five years and 10 months
whatever pistons timeline was as an
undercover agent so
the the days of if somebody messes with
you we're going to take them out
you can't necessarily do that in the
2000s 2002.
so what is the business model if no one
fears you what do people fear that
you're going to do to them if you're not
going to take their lives
well the mob has definitely morphed
itself from
way back in the old days they come to
realize that leaving bodies on the
street is bad for business
okay so they know that so they they yes
they
they are careful they like to operate
more in the gray area like strip clubs
or those corrupt union officials that
they go in they're not as open
shotgun plan like they were in the old
days to try to shake down
everybody and everything because they
know that people are wise to them
so it's kind of a catch-22 for them they
know that the mob runs on fear
but if they can't beat you up and they
can't
kill you how is that fear going to be
generated exactly so it does revert to
sometimes to old-fashioned beatings
you know where they just come they'll
beat you up tune you up and tell you
they're coming back
but then they're also very careful that
they you're going to call the cops and
put them in jail
so it's a delicate dance that the mob
does
now and takes that extra precaution of
of really doing background on an
individual company
or person to see if they're the kind of
people that you could approach because
one false move lands you in jail for
[Music]
extortion